so there was a number of incidents of
sexual violence reported in this
relationship um those um are documented
early on in dr bonnie jacobs notes
where when mr depp was drunk or high he
threw her on the bed ripped off her
nightgown and tried to have sex with her
there were times when he forced her to
give him oral sex when he was angry
these weren't in in loving moments these
were angry moments moments of dominance
moments of him trying to get control
over her
there was a time when they were in
hicksville in in the trailer i must say
trailer park but i guess there's trailer
park
it is a trailer park
where he was accusing her
of of a woman hitting on amber and that
that was the problem amber um
got accused of women hitting on her and
it got accused of men hitting arnold so
there were so many targets that um
came through in his obsessive jealousy
um but when he um on that incident when
kelly sue um
was accused of hitting on miss heard and
they went back into the trailer um mr
depp performed a cavity search and
ostensibly was looking for drugs and
felt it acceptable to rip off her
nightgown and stick his fingers up her
vagina to look for cocaine thought that
maybe she was hiding them there and
again these incidents often happened in
a drug-fueled rage um there was another
incident in the bahamas where when he
got angry
he took his fingers and he put him in
her vagina and moved her around
violently in the closet
again an act of sexual violence
and of course
the incident in australia was one of the
most severe instances of sexual violence
that um misheard had to endure in which
when he was
beating her and choking her and telling
her i'm going to kill you i hate you i
hate you i'm going to kill you when he
grabs a bottle that was on the bar
and penetrated her with that bottle
and miss her reported to me of of
dissociating and
going outside of her body and the only
thing she was thinking is
oh god i hope it's not the broken one
[Music]